-And now we're gonna get to
the news.
After President Biden met last
week with the KPop band BTS,
the White House posted a video
to Instagram
that showed Biden playing
the group's hit song "Butter"
but they cut out the part where
he asked them
to please write a song about
something he's allowed to have.
"'Smooth like hummus,'
how 'bout that?"
President Biden delivered
an address on Thursday night
from the White House and called
on Congress to pass
gun safety legislation, which is
kind of like calling on the Jets
to win the Super Bowl.
You can ask...!
That's right, President Biden
delivered an address
on Thursday night and called on
Congress to ban
assault-style weapons and expand
background checks,
or at the very least get rid of
the vending machines.
Dr. Mehmet Oz last week won
Pennsylvania's
Republican senate primary,
which seems a little crazy,
I mean, is he even qualified...
to be a doctor?!
The House Select Committee
investigating
the Capitol attack will hold its
first public hearing on Thursday
so we can all
finally get to the bottom
of that thing the entire country
watched on live TV in real time.
[ Laughter ]
A man recently threw cake on
the protective glass of
Leonardo da Vinci's
Mona Lisa painting at the Louvre
in Paris, he also threw some on
a Picasso,
but no one noticed.
Yeah, we'll go after Picasso!
You're not off of the hook,
Picasso!
Yesterday was National Hot Air
Balloon Day --
this news was first reported by
a very apologetic
JetBlue gate agent.
[ Laughter ]
Bays and I talked backstage
and we were like,
"I think we put 'JetBlue'
on the balloon."
[ Laughter ]
You know what, I don't think it
would have mattered either way.
During a --
[ Laughs ]
So did you guys
even understand, though?
I feel like you guys don't even
und--
You buy a ticket
on a JetBlue flight,
and then you get to the gate
and they have to apologize
and be like, we're very sorry
it's Hot Air Balloon day,
you got to ride
a hot air balloon.
[ Laughter ]
You know...
We were on hiatus,
we're all a little rusty.
During the parade over the
weekend honoring
her Platinum Jubilee,
a hologram of Queen Elizabeth
was shown in her
gold stagecoach.
And whatever you think
of the queen,
her duet with Tupac
was amazing.
And finally, New York's
LaGuardia Airport
over the weekend debuted
its newly renovated Terminal C,
which features an 11 lane
security screening area.
And this is cool --
one of them is open!
The first lady,
Dr. Jill Biden,
yesterday unveiled
a new postage stamp
that honors former
first lady Nancy Reagan.
The stamp will be very helpful
when you need to figure out
which birthday card
came from your grandparents.
"Let's see -- flower,
flower, Snoopy, Gay Pride.
Oh, here we go!"
Transportation Secretary
Pete Buttigieg announced
yesterday
that he has tested positive
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Unfortunately, he's still not
old enough for the vaccine.
According to reports,
former president Trump's
advisers are divided on
if Trump should announce
his reelection campaign
before this year's
midterm elections or wait
so it does not take attention
away from other candidates.
Oh, because he'd hate
stealing attention.
Trump's like a bridesmaid who
keeps mentioning in her speech
that it's her
half birthday.
According to reports,
former president Trump
may launch his reelection
campaign on July 4th.
So step aside, dogs,
it's our turn to hate that day!
That's a good...
Very good "scared of
a fireworks" dog right there.
That's how you say it --
"a fireworks," right?
Yeah. Yeah. It was --
It sounded weird,
but that's definitely
the way you say it.
The sixth installment
of the dinosaur
sci-fi series called
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
will be released
this Friday in theaters.
Man, if that series
goes on any longer,
they're going to have
to include mammals.
"The horses are out!"
Lawmakers in New York
recently passed the so called
"Stop the Chop" act,
which will allow residents
to sue companies
for excessive
helicopter noise.
So now New York residents
will only have to deal
with noise from garbage trucks,
"sweet-streepers," ambulances,
weed-"wrackers,"
leaf blowers
and people screaming
when a rat pops its head
out of a bodega.
And finally, a guinea pig
in Hungary named Molly
was recently honored
with the Guinness World Record
for most basketball slam dunks
in 30 seconds.
But before you get too excited,
full disclosure,
apparently the rim was only set
at nine feet, six inches.
You know, I was
a little concerned that
that was our closer.
Yeah.
You know, I --
I trust the process.
Bays knows.
I don't know why.
You know what, guys?
Look, the important thing
is we told that joke.
We had the courage
to tell it.
President Biden is reportedly
preparing to forgive $10,000
in student loan debt
for Americans
who make less than $150,000.
$10,000, or, as your college
calls it, a chemistry book.
President Biden traveled today
to Los Angeles.
Not sure what for, but it's got
to have something to do with
"Top Gun."
The public Congressional
hearings on the Capitol attack
kick off tomorrow night
in prime time
and make sure to tune
in afterwards
for "Talking Insurrection"
hosted by Chris Hardwick.
Fox News announced this week
that it will not
carry live coverage
of Congress's prime time
hearings
over the Capitol attack
to focus on more
important news like
would it kill Mulan
to wear a dress?
British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson on Monday
narrowly survived a no
confidence vote in parliament.
And from the looks of him,
he also narrowly
survived electrocution.
"I think the hair
looks quite good.
I think I'll go on, now.
Let everyone know
that I have confidence.
I have confidence
that the hair is good."
According to a new poll,
72% of New Yorkers believe
Mayor Eric Adams
is doing better than
or as well as his predecessor,
Bill de Blasio.
I knew if we just
gave him a chance
he would prove just how much
we didn't like Bill de Blasio.
The CDC this week
raised its monkeypox alert
to level two, though,
if you want people
to take it seriously,
don't change the alert level,
change the name "monkey pox."
Just sounds too cute.
Monkey pox?
Aww, you guys,
should we get it?!
I'm going to get it
for the summer.
A man in California
was arrested this week
for allegedly stealing an
Olympic gold medal from a car.
Officials suspected
the man was guilty
when they very easily
caught up to him.
Singer Jimmy Buffett's
new Margaritaville at Sea
cruise line
recently launched
its first ship
for a one-night-only
inaugural voyage.
And nothing says
safety like "Margaritaville,"
a song that is about
a drunk guy who cuts himself
and decides to get drunker.
There are some people on this
show who are of the age
that we know the plotlines
of the Jimmy Buffett songs.
And finally, at a recent
press conference,
a judge in India
referenced a case
where a man filed
for divorce from his wife
because she cooked him
instant noodles for every meal.
Well, fortunately for that guy,
he's already got a solid idea
of what single life
is going to be like.
House Committee
investigating the Capitol attack
held its first public
hearing tonight
where they called
their first witness --
literally, all of us.
That's right.
The January 6 Committee aired
a 90 minute hearing tonight,
which was carried live
by all the major news networks
except Fox News.
Though Fox ended up
with better ratings
by just airing
the original Capitol attack.
President Biden criticized
the Republican Party
in a new interview
and said it has undergone
a, quote, radical shift
since former president Trump
was elected.
I don't know, I think
they were always this radical,
and then they elected a guy
who couldn't be subtle about it.
It's like when you're
at a dinner party
and you whisper to your wife,
"Dinner parties suck,"
and then she says,
"Dinner parties suck?!"
And then you have to say,
"Okay, yes,
I think dinner parties suck,
everybody!"
President Biden said yesterday
that he's often asked
why he does not play
the political games
that the Republicans play,
and said, quote,
If we do the same thing
they do,
our democracy will
literally be in jeopardy.
Okay, you know, there was
a televised insurrection
hearing tonight, right?
It's already in jeopardy.
That's like the captain
of the Titanic saying,
"I'm worried everyone
running to one side
isn't good for the boat."
Republican Senator John Kennedy
criticized
the Biden administration
yesterday
for not doing more to bring down
high gas prices
and added that it would be,
quote,
excuse me, it would be, quote,
cheaper to buy cocaine
and just run everywhere,
which -- which it's a pretty,
pretty cute joke.
But mostly I want to know,
where are you getting
a gallon of cocaine
for $6?
Don't be stingy, Jack!
Arizona Republican
senate candidate
Blake Masters reportedly met
with conservative activists
earlier this year
at a Phoenix IHOP
and suggested that
the Capitol attack may have been
a false flag operation
set up by the FBI,
which is absolutely
the least crazy idea
ever pitched at
a Phoenix IHOP.
Today was National Sex Day.
Ew!
During the day?!
A group of pro-choice,
topless protesters
with green paint
on their chests
stormed the court of a WNBA game
in Brooklyn this week,
but the NYPD announced
that no charges were filed.
Apparently,
they couldn't make an arrest
because nobody
saw their faces.
"Oh, not I!"
There's no way
I would not look at a face!
The cosmetics company
Nails Inc recently launched
a line of
cheese scented nail polishes.
Or if that's too expensive,
just eat one handful of Cheetos.
And finally, a man in Wales
broke a Guinness world record
after drinking at 56 pubs
in 24 hours.
It was for
"Most sober man in Wales."
And that was the monologue,
everybody, oh!
♪♪